our next guest fun fact swallowed an
entire ring in the seventh grade to get
out of class my kind of girl it's the
[Applause]
it's so cold I'll get down here too
I love you so much I can't take it I
love you so much I can't take it either
by the way how speedy how's it we both
have beardies we both have big juicy
bearded dragons I have some news that I
haven't shared with you oh no
yeah so Speedy uh passed away suddenly
and it was horrible it was sudden and
horrible and um I don't know it's just
bad well so this is um a really upbeat
interview yeah exactly so far okay
speaking of light speaking of living
things yes yes um I know that something
happened to both of us on our birthdays
that's crazy and doesn't I feel happen
to everybody what happened to you
recently on a birthday I made my wish
blew out my candles
and then lit up into flames and set
myself on fire and
what's so crazy is I was at I think my
27th or 28th birthday I can't remember
which year
and I was dancing and I danced right
into a candle on the wall and my whole
house
what is it with birthdays
like a lot of hair came out I'm telling
you I didn't even feel it I didn't even
it was so fast it actually just it
caught on fire and then it just
magically went out I don't know how that
happened so did the video it caught on
fire it went super viral
um
okay now I was so excited because I've
been waiting for season three of making
the cut tell me about season three I've
already seen one and two and I'm mid
binge of season three season three was
so much fun
um I got to judge with Jeremy Scott so
it's me him and Heidi who I just love so
much what does she like because I met
her at a party and the things she told
me I was like whoa yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes thank you yeah
[Applause]
that is the vibe with her and you know
what she also just has such a you know
they say on any set like you can see
from the top down that really sets the
tone of
everyone's attitude and she just has the
best attitude she's like she's like
we're all we're so lucky to be here and
have this job aren't we you know like
that's her attitude and so it it she
demands that type of attitude around her
and it's just like so great I love
working with her she's the best she's I
love her so much and boy is she fun what
we have a clip from making the cut
um let's take a look at it
I think you really have an eye and feel
for fabric and that neckline was so
beautiful I have chickens and I have one
chicken her name is Queen Latifah and
she's about to die oh I'm sorry is this
what you're gonna wear to Queen Latifah
I would like to wear this to Queen
Latino's funeral
it will be my owner
you have a new film and I tried to watch
it but it's not available yet because
it's so fresh out yet it's not out yet
when you tell me about it it's called
first friends what is it tell me about
it so it is a it's a comedy horror movie
um yeah which is yes so much fun best
most successful genres yes put it
together and I'll tell you for me the
best part was we shot it over the summer
and I was just so sick of the Heat and I
was just so badly looking forward to
fall and I got to go on that set and
like drive an hour outside of LA and
really pretend like it was October like
the the house was you know the set was
dressed like it was Halloween I've been
to your house during the holidays like
you do it up no I do it up I live for it
I am obsessed like the second it's fall
I'm like decorate throw me in a Taylor
Swift cover like just like give it to me
I want all the things I've come over and
done gingerbread houses yes me and the
kids and all your kids and then I like
will freak out because I'll look over
and there's Adele and I'm like
I'm friends with her yes yes we are
Adele
and I'm like
hi doll how's it going
like that's how I feel around you even
now I'm just so obsessed with you you
are the ultimate you are an icon 100
times
[Applause]
don't leave we have to go to a
commercial break and up next she's going
to explain how she went from hating one
thing to loving this one thing about
herself which is really interesting
because we all have to grow and change
take a deep look in that mirror and flip
the script don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]